two to five seconds
absolute absence
of symbolization
of describing experience
those are the gym repetitions
you see how fast
we move
away from just abiding
in the Timeless perfection
there's always this seeking impulse
moving away from what we already are
just relax
relax back into the very nature of that
God love light Unity Consciousness that
you already are
and just abide as that repeatedly
throughout the day
those are the gym repetitions
like right now
this is already ineffable perfection
you know that
let's take another inhale and sink
deeper into that Perfection that you
already are
don't let the mind run you away from
that
relax back into the impersonal awareness
into the Transcendent love light
that is your nature at play right now
use the breath as your tool
to sink you deeper and deeper into that
knowledge
into that truth
it's absolute still Perfection behind
and beyond all that is transient and
movable
Saturn under
as has been described for thousands of
years
try this rather than consuming content
these are your gym repetitions
become a gym leader like in Pokemon
we're all just walking each other home
and then weave
weave the sachadananda into the social
fabric
and to your family and to your friends
into your community into the world
so it's meant by Tantra
weave your God realization
come back to the subtle formlessness
through these gym repetitions
away from the physical away from the
finite
away from the transient
away from ego identity name
symbolization
description
more and more towards the ineffable
subtle formless awareness love light
perfection
shared
eternal at play
thank you